dans les zones humides de l'île de la
Réunion une plante s'est installée
le long des ravines à l'ombre des
amoureuses dans les bas à l'ombre des
Tamarins dans les Hauts le bois de
négresse a réussi le tour de force peut
trouver sa place
c'est spécificités lui ont permis d'être
performantes dans cette concurrence à la
vie
pourvu qu'elle ait les pieds dans l'eau
elle est capable de germer à l'ombre sur
un sol pierreux dans les maigres
fissures qui cisaillent la roche sa
croissance est très rapide et de petites
colonies s'installe rapidement dès
qu'une place devient disponible
en effet un arbre qui meurt ou un
glissement de terrain laisse le champ
libre quelque temps à la conquête de ce
nouveau site par les espèces
environnantes ainsi le bois de nez reste
est parfaitement adapté à cette
compétition et il s'en sort plutôt bien
suivant les sols ou les altitudes il va
adopter des morphologies et des couleurs
très différentes
tant au petit en colonie d'arbres
miniatures tantôt arbrisseau sous les
embruns d'une cascade ou encore arbustes
de 3 mètres dans les Hauts tantôt d'un
verre tendre dans un sous-bois tantôt
présentant des jeunes feuilles rouges
les feuilles s'agence toujours de la
même façon et ressemble à si méprendre à
des feuilles peinées
en effet elle pousse de façon alterne le
long des ramilles toutes orientées vers
la lumière pourtant ce sont bien de
petites feuilles indépendantes les unes
des autres
toute l'année de petites fleurs
apparaissent accrochées sur les ramilles
à l'échelle des feuilles
la plante est dyoïque c'est à dire qu'il
existe des pieds mâles et des pieds
femelles
tous deux cohabitent côte à côte et
malgré l'aide de quelques insectes ils
n'ont aucune difficulté pour se
reproduire
des fleurs mâles s'ouvrent nombreuses
délicates et d'une finesse extrême plus
ou moins teintée de rouge
le pollen emporté par le vent tombe
directement dans les fleurs femelles
alentours
les fleurs femelles sont vertes
légèrement rehaussées de rouge et
surmontés d'un petit fruit qui va
gonfler et grossir petit à petit
jusqu'à la maturité complète du fruit
les pétales vont marquer la présence de
la fleur femelle qui s'est transformée
de minuscules graines s'échapperont au
gré du vent ou de l'eau à la recherche
d'un endroit pour accoster d'autres
germeront sur place au pied de leurs
parents et viendront occuper les espaces
vides
là encore des graines sont arrivées un
jour grâce au vent à la mer ou accrocha
au plumes danoiseau et ont investi des
zones propices à leur développement leur
faculté d'adaptation ont fait le reste
jouant des coudes avec leurs adversaires
ce frayant un chemin dans les coursives
de la vie